hola qué tal esta vez imaginemos lo
siguiente trata de imaginarte que tú
eres un anciano matemático y filósofo y
entonces estabas tratando de explicar
algo lo mejor posible acerca de
matemáticas entonces al ser un filósofo
matemático eres capaz de definir los de
una forma exacta entonces tenemos lo
siguiente vamos a hablar acerca de
operaciones de multiplicación y división
con simplemente números entonces tenemos
lo siguiente hay algunas cosas por
considerar entonces vamos a iniciar
asumiendo o suponiendo lo siguiente
entonces si definimos algún tipo de
operación la cual la llamaremos división
entonces tienes un número que se divide
entre otro número pero a la vez esta
operación división está multiplicada por
el mismo número que estabas dividiendo
entonces esta operación te va a dar el
número inicial nos dará el número
inicial que era x
entonces esto pasa porque cuando
nosotros dividimos y luego multiplicamos
por los números regulares por el que
estamos dividiendo si yo tengo 3
dividido entre 2 y luego esta operación
a multiplicó por 2 me volverá a dar 3 y
bien esta es nuestra primera afirmación
y luego si dijéramos lo siguiente
tenemos un número equis y siempre va a
pasar esto un número equis x 0 esta
operación siempre va a hacer 0 siempre
va a ser 0 para cualquier x cualquier
número x 0 va a ser igual a 0 y quizás
esto te suene muy natural te salga muy
del corazón pues es un tanto fácil de
entender pero pues yo quiero extender
nuestras matemáticas y entonces vamos a
lo siguiente vamos a términos en los
cuales utilizaremos dichas afirmaciones
o suposiciones entonces para nuestra
primera parte vamos a asumir que tenemos
una x distinta de 0 aquí lo interesante
a lo que queremos llegar es lo muy
sonado para cuando divides un número
entre 0 entonces nuestra prima
su posición es cuando x es distinto de 0
y luego bien digamos que la mejor forma
de empezar esto de explicar cuando un
número está dividido entre 0 es
suponiendo que está definido entonces
digamos que x sobre 0 va a ser igual a
10 a un número equis pero bueno lo voy a
cambiar para que no te confundas con
esta primera afirmación entonces digamos
que x dividido entre 0 va a ser igual a
un número caja a cualquier número k pero
bueno entonces si esto fuera verdad si
esto fuera cierto que al dividir x entre
0 está definido entonces luego si nos
vamos a nuestra afirmación oa lo que
asumimos en un inicio y multiplicamos
esta operación por 0 pues supuestamente
esto nos tendría que dar simplemente x
pero recuerda lo que hacemos de un lado
de una ecuación hay que hacerlo de ambas
partes para no alterar la y entonces voy
a multiplicar también mi cara por 0 y
bueno ahora sí regresando a nuestra
afirmación de un inicio vemos que un
número dividido
pero un número cualquiera y multiplicado
por este número cualquiera nos da el
número inicial y entonces aquí nos clase
implemente x y con nuestra segunda
suposición y afirma su afirmación
sabemos que cualquier número x cero es
cero entonces aquí tendríamos que x es
igual a cero pero esta es una
contradicción nosotros supusimos que
teníamos una x distinta de 0 esto es una
contradicción y no voy a quitar o vamos
a dejar de lado la idea principal lo que
definimos en un inicio porque son
afirmaciones y nunca nunca van a ser
falsas entonces al dividirlo por un
número y multiplicarlo por ese número
nos va a quedar el número inicial
entonces qué es lo que nos lleva a esta
contradicción qué es lo que nos lleva
esta contradicción pues fue haber
definido que x sobre 0 era igual acá
entonces acá está indefinido es por eso
tan sonado cuando dicen que un número
dividido entre 0 no está definido
entonces esto es para cuando x es
distinta de 0 pero qué pasaría si x es
igual a 0
bueno pues pensemos un poco en esto así
que una vez más tratar de definirlo así
que supondremos supondremos que
asumiremos que 0 entre 0 va a ser igual
a algún número digamos que va a ser a un
número digamos que otra vez es un número
que cualquier número k pero bueno déjame
pongo de otro color
nuestro cero para que hagan distinción
de la idea entonces vamos a utilizar la
misma lógica anterior vamos a usar el
magenta para este 0 el 0 de abajo
digamos que lo pondremos otro color que
representa en lo que estamos dividiendo
y entonces con la misma lógica ahora si
multiplicamos dicha ecuación por el
número que estamos dividiendo
número que estamos dividiendo como lo
hicimos de esta primera parte entonces
multiplicamos por un 0 azul por el 0
azul entonces siguiendo esta lógica esta
afirmación
esto nos tendría que dar el 0 de color
magenta pues estamos dividiendo entre un
número y luego multiplicando por dicho
número nos queda el 0 magenta y como lo
que hicimos anteriormente si
multiplicamos de un lado hay que hacerlo
de ambas las demás partes de la ecuación
para no alterar la simplemente
multiplicamos cada por 0 y esto va a ser
igual a 0 entonces si te das cuenta en
esta parte no estamos encontrando
ninguna contradicción estamos siguiendo
nuestras afirmaciones y estamos llegando
a un resultado que suena coherente aquí
tendríamos que sería 0 igual a está por
0 y no estamos llegando a ninguna
contradicción entonces qué es lo que
pasa aquí entonces si estoy siguiendo a
mis afirmaciones iniciales si no estoy
llegando a ninguna contradicción si
observamos mejor esto yo lo definí
para cualquier k esto es verdad para
cualquier cara y aquí algo que llegamos
es que esto es para cero y nosotros no
queremos llegar a que esto es cero ni al
menos uno ni a uno de algún número
específico sino que sea para cualquier k
que queda puede hacer 75.200 etcétera
para cualquier caso para cualquier k así
que no lo puedo no lo puedo determinar
no podemos decir que acá estrictamente
debería ser entonces por eso decimos y
obtenemos más matiz en las matemáticas
con estos resultados para cuando decimos
que la división de 0 entre 0 está
indeterminada pues nosotros no sabemos
qué será no hay una respuesta
consistente aquí por lo que entonces se
le llama indeterminado no es una
excelente respuesta pero luce mejor que
cualquier otra pero ahora veremos un
mejor matiz con estos resultados
entonces por eso decimos que uno o
cualquier número dividido entre 0 no lo
puedes definir pues no nos deja y nos
deja contradicciones el resultado y que
siero entre 0 esto no
está determinado y cuando llegues a
niveles más elevados de matemáticas
seguido escucharás esto en sus cursos de
cálculo muy seguido que es 0 / 0 está
indeterminado y en determinado muy bien